I guess one question I think I always
have to talk to people about is
when does freemium sort of make sense?
Or what is the advantage
of going with freemium and
how is it different from
other typical models?
And then why is it good for
a subscription software company?
The reason you approach freemium
is because the idea is, one,
you approach your free users
as if they're lead generation.
And that they're part of your
marketing side of the equation,
like these people are the ones who
can get the word out on there.
And the most important thing that
you should be aware of is like.
Is the market large enough that
a small conversion of those people
using the product is enough
to make the company large?
So for example, a local bakery can
only serve people within a small area,
their potential market
size is a lot smaller.
So you can't just give ton away for
free because that conversion rate
won't make that business sustain.
But when you have an internet
software company.
The marginal cost of replication
of offering services is very,
very cheap and the potential
size of the market is huge,
because it's the whole world,
everyone on the Internet and
those forms are big enough,
like all of the use cases for it.
If you have a software
that is very niche, and
that the cost of each new user or
free user is extremely high,
you want to rethink maybe
the mechanics of using freemium.
Like, it's not a one size fits all for
every company.